hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
video I'm going to answer a question
from one of my YouTube viewers
Kix who started a new clothing line and
one of my advice they wrote in saying hi
how're you doing I'm trying to start a
clothing company with my friend but a
budget is really low can you help kicks
so a couple of things for you kicks
starting the clothing line is definitely
capital intensive and you want to try to
make sure you're not spending a lot of
money until you're making money so my
advice to you is dream big have this big
vision if we want to go but start super
small and start going to customers who
you think have a need and get them to
place some orders before you're actually
spending any money and I know it's hard
cuz you don't have samples to go in and
show them and you're using you know
paper or using a computer or laptop to
show them designs but it's super
important to go out and get some orders
and make sure you're on the right track
before you start spending a lot of money
on different designs that flame out and
it happens all the time we spend a ton
of money creating your samples or create
an entire line and you produce it and
you try to sell it and nobody wants to
buy it and that's that's the problem you
want to avoid so you want to make sure
you're on the right track and you can
sell whatever you're going to make so go
and start talking to customers and get
them to place orders before you make
anything and make that a goal of your
business it's a lot tougher to get it
started but you're much more likely to
be successful because when you do launch
you'll have paying customers in hand
ready to buy from you the best way to do
this I think is go after the business
market and what I would try to do is
talk to companies who are local to you
you can get access to who are aggressive
on the marketing may be a little bit
edgy and could see working with you to
create something that could help promote
their business so I don't know what you
sell in the fashion business but said's
t-shirts I go and try to find a company
who again is it a little bit edgier it's
been a lot on marketing and offered to
create a custom t-shirt line for them
that can help expose their business to a
greater audience and that way when
you're doing with the business instead
of dealing with consumers a you have
somebody who is probably going to be
businessperson for you and they're
making much bigger orders so you might
sell 100 t-shirts you might sell a
thousand t-shirts and that's from one
customer instead of trying to make one
sale here one sale there to individual
consumers so it's a great way to get
cash flow positive start building money
into the business and then you can
expand it and later go after the
consumer market but I'd see if I could
start off going after the business
market the last thing I would do is also
try to model success so there's a ton of
fashion guys who've made it big started
from nothing and look at what they did
to be successful so again if your
t-shirts look at Johnny Cupcakes which
has an actual store look at Threadless
which is all online and see if there's
something that you can model from them
and other companies that you look up to
look how they got started how they make
extra money now doesn't really concern
you but how do they go from nothing to
those first few orders to you know
having a full-time business they can
support themselves off of those are some
lessons there that you can learn to help
great business so I hope that helps
kicks good luck sounds exciting if you
guys like the video please give it a
thumbs up and I'd also love to hear
feedback if you want to comment in the
video those comments help me determine
what new videos to make so I really look
forward to them that keeps me going so
please leave a comment and stay tuned
for the next episode
you